you look at the
Kardashians they're making billions you
look at those real housewife shows
they're making money hand over fist cuz
that's what women are watching the money
listens you don't want to watch this
[__] you're watching this
[__] they just shoot it over there
drowning these [__] in money purses
and shoes and Botox it's just
raining it's raining
money yeah so the money listens you'd
rather watch that [__] Real Housewives
bunch of women just tearing each other
down well maybe that's why your husband
left you maybe that's why your husband
left that's why you can't have kids
[__] that's why your asses as flat as
your titties [__]
right that's the message you sent